Ubisoft brought the tears and the cheers
earlier today but now it's time to talk
about Sony make sure you're subscribed
so you don't miss any of the press
conferences we're covering and all the
other stuff we're making for you here at
e3 but for now here's what Sony brought
Sony kicked off its press conference
with the game I'm actually looking
forward to most uncharted for the Lost
Legacy it looks like Chloe and Nadine
will get up to all kinds of classic
Uncharted shenanigans like precarious
climbing driving a whole lot of falling
and facing off against a new nasty
uncharted 4 antagonist the game looks
great gives me more Uncharted goodness
and stars Claudia Black I could not ask
for more they kept the DLC coming with
horizon zero dawn story DLC the frozen
wilds alloy is back and this time she's
off to a land like no other where
Warriors venture to prove themselves in
the hunt but alloy is there to
investigate the ominous erupting
Mountain guarded by an unseen beast no
word on an exact date but the frozen
wilds will be out this year
then studios followed up with a gameplay
trailer for dayz gone which showed off
deacons and John's trusty motorbike a
brutal brawl stealth in through bushes
and evading creepy men hanging from the
ceiling which Sony decided to copy IRL
on stage for some reason it was odd
anyway we also saw a deacon laying traps
in an enemy camp only to come across a
massive creeper hoard where Ben showed
off how many zombies they could render
on screen at once for the second year
running it looks like you'll be able to
use those hordes against your enemies to
out of absolutely nowhere Sony announced
monster hunter world for early 2018 we
saw a character in what looked like a
ghillie suit sneaking through the jungle
trying to avoid detection you can attack
creatures by jumping onto their backs
and there's a rope hook you'll be able
to attach to flying enemies if you want
to go for a ride the classic monster
hunter roast meat is also confirmed for
monster hunter world the surprises
continued as a Shadow of the Colossus
remake was revealed for ps4 remake which
will arrive in 2018 from Japan studio
and BluePoint games has the same
towering bodies and horse-riding
as well as hopefully refined camera
controls if you're more of a fighting
game fan Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite was
shown off - it'll be out on September
19th but you can download a story
today as in right now today fighters
include Dante Gamora Rocket Raccoon
Thanos Hulk and black panther call of
duty World War 2 multiplayer made its
debut with a new trailer taking a cue
from battlefield 1 world war 2 will
feature bayonets trench warfare and
battles across Europe there also appears
to be controllable planes it looks like
a more grounded but no less frenetic
version of the multiplayer you'd expect
from Call of Duty my second major
freakout of III came and used that
Skyrim will be playable in VR I don't
even have anything else to say about it
yet because they haven't added anything
but oh my god in things that further the
comforting news that Sony has not
forgotten about VR they then showed off
a new futuristic platform adventure that
looks bright mysterious and hopefully
not motion sickness inducing called
Starchild I'm not one for fun and games
personally so the next VR game from
supermassive games the developers of
until dawn looks right up my alley
the impatient is set in what looks like
a 1960s mental asylum where you'll be
playing a patient trying to escape I
can't wait to lose sleep with this one
square then reveal the final fantasy 15
fishing game called monster of the deep
which will be out this September and let
you go fishing with all your bros since
we're here let's keep those VR wheels
turning with the adorable and charming
Maus apart from a threatening Cobra at
the end man covers it in this year it
looks like we can expect puzzling and
action gameplay in a lovely vibrant game
world with a Maus protagonist it's about
time we saw everyone's favorite angsty
teen Kratos in a new God of War trailer
still sporting that impressive new beard
and ice axe Kratos set out to protect
and train his young companion in the
game's varied settings we saw oceans
snow-capped mountains glittering rivers
and forests ruins most interestingly we
got a look into the relationship between
Kratos and the boy and another giant
snake another of my massively
anticipated games Detroit become human
with showing off or once again a new
gameplay trailer showed off the snowy
city of Detroit and the excellent Jesse
Williams as Marcus an Android and one of
the title characters the game's choice
system was also shown off when the
player was spotted by police and overlay
showed three different reactions to the
situation and at the end we saw a
massive flowchart of how the city
could have played out in classic Quantic
Dream's styled the story of androids
trying to take back control of their
lives seems complex and the character
models look excellent destiny - took the
spotlight with a new gameplay trailer
that sets up the stakes of Bungie sequel
goal thinks the Guardians no longer fear
death and he's here to change it
PlayStation will also get exclusive
content including gear a city apex ship
exotic weapon the borealis PvP map
retribution and the lake of Shadows
strike
Sony closed out the show with a look at
PlayStation exclusive spider-man from
insomniac games and you gameplay demo
let us watch Spidey set traps traverse
the environment stealthily take down
foes and wrap people up with webs also
highlighted with a fair bit of combat
featuring slow-mo while selecting
attacks and diving through bullets in
slow motion it all looked a little like
the Arkham games
Spidey can also execute finishing moves
and to manipulate the environments to
take out foes it looks like there will
be on Rails scenes peppered with
QuickTime events as well whether or not
Spidey is your superhero of choice
insomniac sentry certainly looks like
it'll make you feel heroic as hell it'll
land in 2018 oh and Miles Morales is in
it so that's Sony and that's everything
for the second day of III do let us know
what you thought of all the
announcements from today and every other
press conference and be sure to check
back tomorrow for Nintendo
you